Tyra: I CONSTANTLY HAVE
PEOPLE COMING UP TO ME,
ASKING ME, "HOW CAN I GET
INTO THE FIELD OF MODELING?"
THAT'S ONE REASON WHY
I STARTED THIS SHOW--
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
♪♪♪
>> Tyra: I WANNA MAKE
A TOP MODEL IN EIGHT WEEKS.
I WANNA TAKE SOMEONE
FROM OBSCURITY TO FAME,
AND I WANNA CHART
THE ENTIRE PROCESS
AND SHOW AMERICA HOW IT HAPPENS.
I LAUNCHED A NATIONWIDE SEARCH,
AND PEOPLE SENT IN TAPES
FROM ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
♪♪♪
>> Tyra: I'M LOOKING FOR
ORIGINALITY, CREATIVITY.
I'M LOOKING FOR HUMOR,
ALL COLORS, ALL SHAPES
AND ALL SIZES.
SOME OF THESE GIRLS
YOU WOULD NOT LOOK AT TWICE
IN THE STREET, BUT I'LL KNOW
WHEN I CAN MAKE THEM
INTO SOMETHING.
BOY, YOU'RE COMING TO L.A.!
Woman: AAH!
Tyra: YOU'RE A SEMI-FINALIST.
Woman #2: AAH!
Tyra: THIS IS A ONCE
IN A LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY.
A LIFE-CHANGING OPPORTUNITY.
WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR IS A STAR.
THAT'S ALL.
♪♪♪
Nicole: I COULDN'T SLEEP
LAST NIGHT.
Christina: JUST
A SMALL TOWN GIRL
HERE IN THE BIG CITY.
Kesse: SMALL TOWN GIRL.
Ebony: THIS IS MY FIRST TIME
ANYWHERE WEST OF MARYLAND.
Woman: I JUST WANNA SAY
WELCOME TO LOS ANGELES
AND WELCOME TO
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
Woman: SO COOL.
Woman #2: I'M SHANNON.
Justine: ADRENALINE'S GOING,
LIKE, A MILLION MILES A MINUTE.
Katie: I'M SO EXCITED
RIGHT NOW.
OH, MY GOD.
I WANT THIS SO BAD.
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND.
Adrianne: I'M WITH MY KIND.
A BUNCH OF AMAZON WOMEN
WITH BIG FEET, AND I FEEL LIKE
I FINALLY FIT IN FOR ONCE.
Natalie: I WAS HOPING THAT
ALL THE GIRLS WERE GONNA BE
REALLY SHORT AND FAT AND UGLY,
AND EVERYBODY'S TALL
AND THIN AND BEAUTIFUL.
Woman: I WAS TALKING
TO ADRIANNE.
Heather: THIS IS LIKE
A ONCE IN A LIFETIME CHANCE.
YOU ALWAYS SAY, LIKE,
"I WANT THAT ONE LITTLE BREAK,"
AND THIS IS IT.
♪♪♪
Michelle: I JUST WANNA SAY
YOU GIRLS ARE REALLY SPECIAL
TO US, BECAUSE WE WATCH
SO MANY TAPES.
I MEAN, THOUSANDS.
BUT REMEMBER, THERE'S ONLY ROOM
FOR TEN IN THE HOUSE,
SO THAT MEANS TEN OF YOU GUYS
WILL BE GOING WITH US
TO NEW YORK,
AND TEN WILL BE RETURNING HOME.
♪♪♪
Women: (screaming)
Tyra: HI.
Kesse: SEEING TYRA BANKS,
SHE'S EVEN MORE BEAUTIFUL
IN PERSON THAN SHE IS
ON THE PICTURES, I THINK.
Robin: OH, MY WORD.
MEETING TYRA WAS AMAZING 'CAUSE
LIKE, WE WERE NOT EXPECTING HER.
Tyra: LIKE, WHERE YOU THE ONE
THAT WAS DOING THIS ON YOUR TAPE?
Woman: OH, THE MOTORCYCLE?
Tyra: ON THE FLOOR,
YOU WERE LIKE--SHE WAS LIKE...
Woman: (laughing)
Tyra: OKAY, MISS "A" TO "Z."
SENSUAL OUTFIT.
>> Christina: "A"
FOR MY AWESOME ABS.
"B" FOR MY BLOSSOMING BREASTS.
Tyra: WHY DON'T YOU TELL
TELL THE TABLE WHAT WAS "W"?
Christina: I LIKE IT WET.
Woman: (hooting)
Tyra: I'LL BE TALKING TO YOU
IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF DAYS
IN YOUR INTERVIEWS
AND ALL THAT KIND OF STUFF,
SO BE GORGEOUS AND BE GREAT.
BYE, Y'ALL!
♪♪♪
Elyse: HI.
Tyra: HELLO.
Elyse: MY NAME IS ELYSE.
I'M 20 YEARS OLD, AND I'M FROM
ALBUQUERQUE, NEW MEXICO.
Tyra: ELYSE,
IS MODELING SOMETHING
THAT YOU'VE HAD A PASSION FOR?
Elyse: WELL, IT'S DEFINITELY
NOT SOMETHING THAT I COULD DO
MY ENTIRE LIFE,
WHEREAS MEDICINE IS.
I AM APPLYING TO MEDICAL SCHOOL.
Woman: WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN
IF YOU HAVE TO PICK AND CHOOSE
BETWEEN BECOMING A SUPERMODEL
OR GOING TO MED SCHOOL?
Elyse: I'VE ACTUALLY THOUGHT
ABOUT THAT, AND MEDICAL SCHOOL
CAN BE DEFERRED INDEFINITELY,
WHEREAS BEING 20 YEARS OLD
CANNOT, SO...
(laughter)
Elyse: MY FRIENDS LAUGH AT ME
ALL THE TIME, AND I THINK
IT'S FUNNY, TOO.
I MEAN, MODELING AND SCIENCE
ARE PRETTY MUCH, I WOULD SAY,
MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE.
IF I HAD TO PICK TEN PEOPLE
TO BE IN THIS HOUSE,
I WOULD NOT BE AMONG THEM.
OH, I'M NOT CONFIDENT AT ALL.
I THINK I'M OUT.
Ebony: MY NAME IS EBONY,
AND I'M ACTUALLY ORIGINALLY
FROM HARLEM.
I KNOW THAT I'M UNIQUE.
I ALWAYS GET THAT SOMETHING
IS DIFFERENT, WHETHER IT'S
MY LOOK, MY PERSONALITY.
SOMETHING IS DIFFERENT.
Tyra: WE KNOW
YOU'RE A LESBIAN.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT EXPRESSING
THAT ON NATIONAL TELEVISION?
Ebony: NOT A PROBLEM, HONEY.
I'M VERY OPEN ABOUT IT.
IN HIGH SCHOOL,
THE LITTLE DRAMA--
THEY FOUND OUT I WAS GAY.
SO I'D GO UP TO
THE GIRLS' LOCKER ROOM,
AND NOBODY WANTED TO
CHANGE WITH ME.
AFTER THAT, I'D WALK INTO
THE BOYS' LOCKER ROOM,
AND THEY ALL GAVE ME FIVE,
AND I CHANGED.
THOSE GIRLS DIDN'T TALK TO ME
FOR ABOUT A MONTH OR TWO,
BUT, YOU KNOW, I DECIDED
I HAVE TO LOVE MYSELF
AND BE TRUE TO ME.
Katie: HI, EVERYONE.
MY NAME IS KATIE.
I GO TO SCHOOL RIGHT HERE
IN BEAUTIFUL WISCONSIN.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
MISCONCEIVE THE WAY I AM,
AND MAYBE, LIKE, TAKE ME
FOR LIKE, "OH, SHE'S, LIKE,
A LITTLE PRISS."
AND THEN PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
THE SIDE OF ME--
LIKE, I LOVE ANIMALS.
NO ONE KNOWS THAT
I AM AN ANIMAL ACTIVIST,
AND I AM WITH P.E.T.A.
I DO HELP THEM
AND E-MAIL CONGRESS,
AND, LIKE, THE WOLVES,
AND, LIKE, TRYING TO SAVE THEM.
LIKE, I JUST SAVED
FIVE POOR BEARS.
AS YOU CAN TELL,
I LOVE LEOPARD AND I LOVE ZEBRA,
AND THIS IS MY ROOM.
Tyra: ARE YOU A VEGETARIAN?
Katie: NO, BUT I EAT CHICKEN,
THAT'S IT.
(laughs)
THAT'S IT. A LITTLE MEAT.
April: WHY DO I WANNA BE
A SUPERMODEL?
YOU GET YOUR HAIR DONE.
YOU GET TO GO TRAVEL THE WORLD.
Ebony: MAKEUP.
LIKE, THE THINGS THEY CAN DO
WITH IT, AND I'M JUST
SO INTERESTED IN, LIKE,
EVERY PART OF IT.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, NATALIE,
THE FIRST THING I'D LIKE YOU
TO DO JUST TO WARM YOU UP
IS JUST TO HAVE YOU PRETEND
LIKE THIS IS THE CATWALK.
Natalie: I COME FROM
A REALLY BROKEN-UP HOME.
MY MOTHER HAS EIGHT KIDS, OKAY?
AND I'M THE OLDEST.
MY MOTHER WAS ON DRUGS, AND SO
ME AND MY TWO YOUNGER SISTERS--
WE WERE ALL RAISED
IN FOSTER CARE.
I DIDN'T HAVE THE PERFECT LIFE.
Tyra: WHY DO YOU WANNA BE
A SUPERMODEL?
Natalie: I WOULDN'T FIT IN
ANYWHERE ELSE, ANY OTHER JOB--
NO DOCTOR, NO LAWYER,
NOTHING LIKE THAT.
I NEED TO BE A SUPERMODEL.
I NEED TO SUCCEED IN SOMETHING,
BECAUSE I HAVE THESE PEOPLE
THAT ARE LOOKING UP TO ME,
AND IF THEY DON'T
SEE ME SUCCEED,
THEN WHAT ARE THEY GONNA DO?
Shannon: HELLO.
HI. I'M SHANNON.
Man: HI, SHANNON.
Tyra: HI, SHANNON.
Shannon: HI.
Woman: HELLO.
Shannon: HELLO.
I WANNA BECOME
AMERICA'S SUPERMODEL.
I AM READY.
I WANNA SHAKE THE DUST
OFF THE SMALL TOWN.
Man: SHANNON, I TAKE IT
YOU'RE A VERY RELIGIOUS PERSON.
HAVE YOU ALWAYS BEEN RELIGIOUS?
Shannon: YES,
EVER SINCE I WAS LITTLE.
I WAS PROBABLY SAVED
AROUND THE AGE OF 10,
BUT I GOT STRONGER OVER
THE YEARS, 'CAUSE, YOU KNOW,
PRACTICE MAKES PERFECT.
Man: IT SAYS
ON YOUR APPLICATION
THAT YOU'RE A VIRGIN.
Shannon: YES, BUT WHEN
I GET MARRIED, I TOLD MY MOM--
I SAID, "MY WEDDING'S
GONNA BE CUT SHORT,
AND I'M GONNA BE GONE, BABY!"
♪♪♪
Justine: I'M JUSTINE,
22 YEARS OLD,
BORN AND RAISED IN CALIFORNIA.
I LOVE ATTENTION.
I, LIKE, TRY TO BE
THE CENTER OF ATTENTION.
I MEAN, I WAKE UP EVERY DAY.
MY MOM CALLS ME.
"YOU'RE GREAT.
YOU'RE WONDERFUL."
I'M LIKE, "YES, I KNOW.
I'M FEELING IT."
Woman: WHAT DO YOU HAVE THAT
THE OTHER BLONDES DON'T HAVE?
Justine: A BETTER-LOOKING
FACE. UM...
I MEAN, AT THIS POINT,
I JUST CAN'T STAND ANYBODY.
THERE'S A FEW THAT I DON'T
EVEN KNOW WHY THEY'RE HERE.
Man: SO THEY CAN'T HOLD
A CANDLE TO YOU.
Justine: OH, NO WAY. NO, NO.
NO.
Woman: THANK YOU.
Justine: I DID GOOD.
I DID GREAT.
I'M THE BEST, I KNOW IT.
♪♪♪
Woman: WE'RE HAVING
A PARTY IN HERE.
Shannon: OH, MY GOD.
THIS IS AWESOME.
I'M HAVING A BLAST.
THIS IS, LIKE,
ONE BIG SLUMBER PARTY.
IT'S SO MUCH FUN.
Elyse: THE GIRLS HAVE NOT
BEEN SIMILAR TO MY EXPECTATIONS.
THEY'RE MUCH NICER.
MY FRIENDS ALL SAID,
"THEY'RE GONNA BE BITCHES."
OF COURSE, NONE OF THEM ARE.
Natalie: I MEAN, I HEARD
ABOUT THE PARTY UPSTAIRS,
BUT IT'S JUST, I WASN'T INVITED.
I'M NOT CLICKING WITH ANYONE.
I DEFINITELY SEE SOME GIRLS
TRYING TOO HARD.
Kesse: MY NAME IS KESSE.
I'M FROM NORTH LITTLE ROCK,
ARKANSAS.
I'M 21.
Man: KESSE, COULD YOU TELL ME
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
YOUR RELATIONSHIP
YOUR MOTHER?
Kesse: MY MOTHER AND I ARE--
WE'RE NOT ON THE BEST OF TERMS
RIGHT NOW.
MY FATHER, UM, HE WAS SHOT
AT ONE POINT
WALKING DOWN AN ALLEY.
I LOVE HIM.
UM, I KNOW HE'S IN
A BETTER PLACE, SO...
SINCE I AM THE TRUE DIVA,
DEVASTATING, INTRIGUING,
VIVACIOUS AND JUST ALL THAT,
IT'S TIME FOR ME
TO TAKE WHAT'S MINE.
I'M NOT HERE TO MAKE FRIENDS.
I UNDERSTAND THIS IS
A COMPETITION, SO I JUST GOTTA
PUT THAT WALL UP, KNOWING THAT
I'M IN THIS TO WIN.
♪♪♪
Adrianne: MY NAME IS
ADRIANNE.
I'M FROM JOLIET, ILLINOIS,
AND I'M 20 YEARS OLD.
(laughs)
I LIVE ALMOST IN THE BOONDOCKS.
NOTHING GOING ON.
I MEAN, YOU CAN GO COW TIPPIN'.
YOU KNOW?
I'M FUNNY. I'M PRETTY.
I GOT PERFECT TEETH.
Tyra: WHAT DO YOU THINK
MAKES YOU SPECIAL?
Adrianne: I'M, LIKE,
A REALLY BIG TOMBOY.
I'M KINDA, LIKE,
ROCK 'N' ROLL ALL THE TIME.
IN HIGH SCHOOL,
I WAS KIND OF A DORK.
I DIDN'T GET ASKED OUT MUCH
AT ALL.
I GOT TURNED DOWN A LOT.
Tyra: WHAT DO YOU THINK
MAKES YOU BETTER?
Shawna: I'M JUST
ON ANOTHER LEVEL.
Christina: MY HAIR
STANDS OUT.
Nicole: I'M IN LAW SCHOOL.
Lenora: THERE'S NOBODY HERE
WITH A BIG AFRO LIKE THIS.
Jakai: OH, I LOVE MY BODY.
SHOOT, Y'ALL WANNA SEE
SOME OF IT RIGHT NOW?
(laughter)
Woman: HERE'S NICOLE.
Nicole: HI.
I GREW UP
IN MURIETTA, CALIFORNIA.
IT'S A SMALL TOWN.
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
REAL TALL AND SKINNY,
MADE FUN OF FOR IT.
Tyra: WHAT WOULD MAKE US
CHOOSE YOU
OVER ALL THE OTHER ONES?
Nicole: WHEN I LOOK
IN THE MAGAZINE,
WHEN I SEE A SUPERMODEL,
WHEN I SEE THAT, I SEE ME.
I PICK--I LOOK
AT EVERY LITTLE DETAIL.
I WANT THIS REALLY BAD.
I WANT THIS REALLY, REALLY BAD,
AND I KNOW EVERYBODY ELSE DOES,
BUT I MEAN,
I REALLY, REALLY WANT THIS.
Robin: HI. I'M ROBIN.
I'M 26 YEARS OLD,
FROM MEMPHIS, TENNESSEE.
I'VE BEEN
MISS SHELBYVILLE, TENNESSEE.
Y'ALL DON'T PROBABLY KNOW
ABOUT THAT.
AND, UM, I COMPETED
IN MISS LIBERTYLAND,
MISS SOYBEAN FESTIVAL,
AND I WON.
I COME FROM PAGEANTRY.
PAGEANTRY ACTUALLY PUT ME
THROUGH SCHOOL.
SO THOSE THAT SAY
THAT PAGEANT GIRLS ARE JUST,
YOU KNOW, DITZY
IS NOT TRUE.
Tyra: WHO WERE YOU
LOOKING AT OVER THERE?
Robin: OH, I GOT THAT
FROM MISS TYRA BANKS,
'CAUSE IN VICTORIA'S SECRET,
SHE WAS LOOKING LEFT AND RIGHT,
AND I WAS LIKE, "GO, DIVA!"
Tyra: BEING A SUPERMODEL,
YOU HAVE TO HAVE
THAT CONFIDENCE,
SO WHAT DO YOU THINK PHYSICALLY
IS SO GREAT ABOUT YOU
THAT'S BETTER THAN THEM?
Robin: I USED TO WEIGH
204 POUNDS, SO I'M THANKFUL
FOR THIS BODY RIGHT HERE.
IF YOU LOOK AT
THE AVERAGE WOMAN, THAT'S ME.
I MEAN, YOU CAN'T GET
ENOUGH OF ME.
I'M UNIQUE, I'M FUN.
I DON'T HAVE TO SAY IT,
'CAUSE FIVE MINUTES
OF BEING AROUND ME,
YOU'LL KNOW IT.
YOU'LL GO BACK
AND TELL A FRIEND.
Tyra: OKAY, ROBIN,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
Nicole: I DON'T KNOW
IF I'M GOING TO NEW YORK,
BUT I HOPE SO.
Woman: AAH.
Katie: I THINK I DID REALLY GOOD,
'CAUSE I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING FOR,
AND I WISH I WAS
A LITTLE TALLER.
Justine: I WAS JUST
SITTING BACK,
WATCHING ALL THESE CHICKS,
ANNOYING EVERYBODY.
I FEEL LIKE EVERYONE'S
PUSHING ME, LIKE, OUT.
Adrianne: IT'S JUST WEIRD
WHEN YOU'RE LIKE
THIS GHETTO WHORE GIRL,
AND YOU COME HERE,
AND YOU'RE LIKE,
"OH, I'M CLEAN," AND THEN
YOU HAVE TO GO BACK.
Elyse: WE'RE ALL
FREAKING OUT FOR SOME REASON.
LIKE, I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT IT IS.
Women: (laughing)
Tyra: HEY, PRETTY GIRLS.
Women: HI!
Tyra: OKAY, YOU GUYS,
I'M LOOKING FOR TEN GIRLS,
BUT THE PRODUCERS AND I
CAN ONLY AGREE ON 8.
THE FIRST YOUNG WOMAN THAT'S
COMING TO NEW YORK CITY IS...
NICOLE.
Women: (cheering)
Tyra: THE SECOND WOMAN
COMING TO NEW YORK--
MISS SOYBEAN!
Women: (cheering)
Tyra: KESSE.
Women: WHOO!
Tyra: ELYSE.
Y'ALL, THE DOCTOR'S
COMING TO NEW YORK.
KATIE.
THE NEXT GIRL THAT'S COMING
TO NEW YORK CITY REALLY DOESN'T
HAVE FAR TO GO BECAUSE
SHE'S FROM NEW YORK CITY,
AND IT'S MISS EBONY.
Women: (cheering)
Tyra: ALL RIGHT.
ONLY HAVE TWO MORE.
THE NEXT WOMAN
COMING TO NEW YORK CITY--
ADRIANNE.
Women: WHOO!
Adrianne: YEAH!
Tyra: ALL RIGHT.
AND THERE'S ONLY MORE,
YOU GUYS, AND THE PRODUCERS
HAVE BEEN FIGHTING
TOOTH AND NAIL,
AND OUR FINAL GIRL...
IS SHANNON.
Woman: WHOO!
Shannon: I WAS SO EXCITED.
MY, LIKE, HEART
JUST, LIKE, SANG.
Justine: I'M OKAY.
I MEAN, I DON'T KNOW.
I JUST KIND OF...
WANNA GO, YOU KNOW?
Katie: I DON'T EVEN--
IT'S NOT EVEN REAL RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW.
I'M, LIKE, IN A DAZE.
Natalie: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'M JUST REALLY SAD.
I WANTED THIS A WHOLE LOT.
I'M CRUSHED.
MY FEELINGS ARE CRUSHED.
I WANNA BE A GOOD SPORT
AND SAY THAT, "WELL,
AT LEAST I MADE IT THIS FAR."
BUT NO. I'M NOT GONNA LIE.
YOU KNOW, I WANTED THIS.
Kesse: I'M GOING
TO NEW YORK, SO...
OH, MY GOSH.
Adrianne: I KIND OF FEEL LIKE
I'M GONNA THROW UP.
Katie: IS THIS REALLY HAPPENING?
♪♪♪
Ebony: I'M ORIGINALLY
FROM NEW YORK.
YOU KNOW, HEARING GIRLS
FROM ALL AROUND THE WORLD
AND THEM SAYING,
"GOD, IT'S MY FIRST TIME HERE."
Women: (screaming)
Ebony: AND IT'S LIKE,
I'M IN NEW YORK
WITH A WHOLE NEW LIGHT.
Adrianne: WHOO!
♪♪♪
Elyse: "WELCOME TO NEW YORK.
CONGRATULATIONS
ON YOUR ARRIVAL.
ENCLOSED ARE THE KEYS
TO YOUR PENTHOUSE.
HEAD ON UPSTAIRS,
FIND YOUR BEDS,
CLAIM YOUR SPACE
AND EXPLORE YOUR NEW HOME."
Shannon: YEAH!
Shannon: OH, MY GOSH!
GIRL, WHICH ROOM
ARE WE GOING TO FIRST?
Elyse: COMING TO
THE PENTHOUSE WAS INCREDIBLE.
Adrianne: WHOO!
Shannon: GO, BABY!
Kesse: OUR VIEWS FROM
OUR ROOMS ARE JUST AWESOME.
I WAS JUST LIKE, "OH, MY GOSH.
YOU'VE GOTTA BE KIDDING ME."
Ebony: I LOVE IT.
FENG SHUI? FENG SHUI?
Shannon: EVERY ROOM HAS,
LIKE, ITS OWN UNIQUE FLAIR,
LIKE PARIS OR MILAN OR TOKYO.
THAT'S WHAT'S SO NEAT.
IT'S, LIKE, HAVING ITS OWN,
LIKE, SENSE OF STYLE.
Katie: I LIKE THIS ONE.
Elyse: YOU GUYS
DOWN WITH THIS ONE?
I GOT MY FIRST CHOICE,
WHICH WAS THE TOKYO ROOM
WITH NICOLE AND KATIE.
Kesse: I REALLY WANTED
TO ROOM WITH ROBIN
BECAUSE SHE'S LIKE MY SISTER,
AND SHE'S A CHRISTIAN.
Robin: WE GONNA NAME OUR ROOM
"THE DIVA ROOM."
DIVA ROOM!
Adrianne: YOU KNOW WHAT?
HOW ABOUT THIS?
I'M SO HAPPY I'M HERE.
NOBODY WANTS THIS F'n ROOM.
I'LL TAKE IT.
Shannon: I THINK
THEY GOT US TOGETHER.
Robin: THEY'RE LIKE..
Shannon: WE'RE READING
THE BIBLE TOGETHER.
Robin: IT IS SO IRONIC
BECAUSE MISS KESSE
AND MISS SHANNON--
ALL THREE OF US ARE CHRISTIANS.
SO WE HAVE, LIKE,
THAT ONE THING IN COMMON.
Elyse: THE GIRLS IN MILAN
SEEM TO BE JUST
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE WORLD.
THE SEPARATION
BETWEEN THE TWO ROOMS
HAS A LOT TO DO WITH RELIGION.
I'M NOT INTERESTED
IN HAVING QUIET TIME
TO READ THE BIBLE.
I AM A MILITANT ATHEIST.
Shannon: ALL RIGHT, LADIES,
I GOTTA SHOW YOU SOMEBODY
I WANNA MEET.
Robin: WHO?
Shannon: HIS NAME IS
BRAD PINKERT.
FAVORITE BOOK--
THE BIBLE, LADIES.
Robin: YAY!
Shannon: THE BIBLE, THIS GUY!
I'M SAVING MYSELF
FOR WHEN I GET MARRIED,
BUT I'VE KISSED A GUY BEFORE.
DON'T GET ME WRONG.
BUT THAT'S ABOUT AS FAR
AS I WOULD.
I'M PRETTY INNOCENT.
SO THIS GUY'S GOING UP
WHERE I CAN SEE HIM.
AND I'M-A MEET THIS KID SOMEDAY.
WHEREVER YOU ARE, BOY,
I'M-A COME FIND YOU.
Katie: WE HAVE, LIKE,
STORAGE, TOO,
UNDERNEATH OUR BEDS.
I DON'T KNOW IF THIS PULLS OUT.
Elyse: YEAH, IT DOES.
Katie: OH, WAIT, YOU GUYS,
THERE'S AN EXTRA BED.
Nicole: FOR BOYFRIENDS?
Elyse: WE SAW SOME
PULLOUT BEDS
UNDERNEATH OUR BEDS,
AND WE SAID, "LOOK AT THIS.
WE HAVE BEDS THAT
OUR BOYFRIENDS CAN SLEEP ON
WHEN THEY COME TO VISIT US."
AND THAT TURNED OUT
NOT TO BE THE CASE.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT,
SO I JUST WANNA CONGRATULATE
YOU GUYS.
WELCOME TO NEW YORK CITY--
THE N.Y.C.
WE'RE SO CLOSE TO TIMES SQUARE.
ISN'T THAT CRAZY? RIGHT?
YOU GUYS, YOU KNOW, ARE
OUR EIGHT FINALISTS, AND, UM,
BUT I LIKE VERY ROUND NUMBERS,
SO WHAT I DID IS I DID
A NATIONWIDE SEARCH
FOR TWO MORE.
Robin: OH, MY WORD.
Elyse: I WAS LIKE, "WHAT?"
I HAD LITERALLY JUST SAID
A MINUTE BEFORE, "GIRLS,
I'M GLAD IT'S THE EIGHT OF US."
Tyra: SO COME ON IN HERE,
TESSA AND GISELLE.
Ebony: THESE--WHOA.
All: HI.
Tyra: THIS IS GISELLE.
Giselle: I'VE BEEN
IN THE SPOTLIGHT,
LIKE, MY WHOLE LIFE.
I'VE BEEN A PERFORMER.
I'VE BEEN DANCING SINCE I WAS 3.
Tyra: GISELLE'S PERSONALITY
IS SO STRONG.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT SHE'S
A LATINA WOMAN.
THAT WAS VERY IMPORTANT TO ME.
I THOUGHT TESSA REPRESENTED
AN EXOTIC VARIATION
OF A CLASSIC BLONDE LOOK.
Tessa: I'M FROM CHICAGO.
I'M A HOSTESS.
I'M, LIKE, THE GIRL NEXT DOOR.
IT WAS A LITTLE TOUGH
MEETING THE GIRLS
FOR THE FIRST TIME.
I NOTICED THEM CHECKING ME,
LIKE, FROM UP AND DOWN,
YOU KNOW.
JUST, "I DON'T KNOW
IF I LIKE THIS GIRL."
Tyra: ALL RIGHTY,
SO I WANNA WELCOME
ALL YOU GUYS.
SO I WANNA LET YOU GUYS KNOW,
YES, YOU GUYS ARE HERE
BECAUSE YOU'RE BEAUTIFUL,
BUT WHAT STOOD OUT IS SOMETHING
THAT--JUST THAT "IT" THING,
THAT SPECIAL THING.
IT'S A PERSONALITY.
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS
THAT IT TAKES TO BE A TOP MODEL,
AND YOU GUYS ARE GONNA BE
PUT THROUGH LOTS
OF DIFFERENT TESTS.
THERE'S GOING TO BE
PHOTO SHOOT TESTS,
MEDIA TRAINING,
HOW TO SPEAK LIKE A SUPERMODEL
AND REPRESENT TOP COMPANIES.
YOU KNOW, IT TAKES MODELS YEARS
TO EVEN JUST GET THESE PEOPLE
TO TAKE ONE GLANCE AT THEM.
ONCE A WEEK,
YOU'LL BE EVALUATED,
AND ONCE A WEEK,
SOMEONE WILL BE ELIMINATED.
ONE OF YOU IS GONNA BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
YOU'RE GONNA START OFF WITH
A MODELING CONTRACT WITH REVLON.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
A FASHION SPREAD
IN "MARIE CLAIRE" MAGAZINE
AND A CONTRACT WITH MAJOR
MODELING AGENCY WILHELMINA.
Women: WHOO!
Shannon: YOU GUYS RESEMBLE...
Katie: WE'RE SECRETLY
SISTERS.
Giselle: KATIE AND I
ARE VERY, VERY SIMILAR,
SO, I MEAN, IF THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR THAT, UH, EXOTIC-TYPE LOOK,
THERE'S MAJOR COMPETITION
BETWEEN US.
THAT'S OKAY.
I THINK SHE'S BEAUTIFUL.
I KNOW THAT SHE'S OLDER THAN ME,
SO THAT'S OKAY.
Tessa: AT FIRST,
I DID NOT LIKE NICOLE.
SHE WAS MY COMPETITION.
YOU KNOW, I LOOKED AT HER,
I WAS LIKE,
"OH, SHE'S JUST GORGEOUS."
GORGEOUS HAIR. SHE HAS IT ALL.
TOTAL PACKAGE.
SHE JUST HAS, LIKE, EVERYTHING
THAT EVERYBODY WANTS.
Giselle: HAS EVERYONE
PICKED OUT THEIR ROOM
AND EVERYTHING?
Katie: SO... YEAH.
Giselle: OH, I SEE.
Katie: HERE'S THIS. I DON'T KNOW...
Tessa: EVERYBODY ALREADY
HAD THEIR ROOMS PICKED OUT,
SO GISELLE AND I
GOT THE BUNK BEDS.
Adrianne: I WANNA THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
YOU'RE LIKE AN ANGEL.
AS SOON AS I HEARD,
"DOES ANYONE ELSE SMOKE?"
I'M LIKE, OH!
Tessa: ADRIANNE AND I--
RIGHT WHEN WE GOT IN THE HOUSE,
WE GO AND PICK A CORNER
TO GO SMOKE AT.
THERE'S ONLY TWO OF US
THAT SMOKE.
SO WE GOT A GOOD SMOKING SPOT,
THOUGH.
Adrianne: YEAH, Y'ALL, YEAH.
Robin: Y'ALL KNOW WHAT?
THE SMOKING THING...
Tessa: AND MISS ROBIN
COMES OUT AND STARTS SCREAMING,
LIKE, "THIS WHOLE HOUSE
STINKS NOW.
YOU GUYS CAN'T SMOKE."
Robin: IT'S LIKE,
IT'S ALL IN HERE, AND Y'ALL KNOW
THAT SMOKE, LIKE, GETS IN
PEOPLE'S CLOTHES AND THEIR HAIR.
Shannon: ROBIN--I FEEL LIKE
SHE'S LIKE THE MOTHER
IN THE HOUSE.
Tessa: IT WAS A BIG DEAL,
AND THAT'S WHY I WAS SO NERVOUS.
I WAS LIKE, "GREAT. YOU KNOW,
THIS IS ALL I NEED."
Robin: BUT YOU KNOW,
I DON'T MIND Y'ALL
KILLING Y'ALL SELF,
BUT, YOU KNOW, MAMA WANNA LIVE!
Elyse: WE HAD A COUPLE OF
SPECIAL VISITORS.
(knock on door)
Jon: ANYBODY HOME?
Elyse: ONE OF WHOM
WAS A PERSONAL TRAINER.
>> Jon: JUST SO EVERYBODY KNOWS,
MY NAME IS JON,
AND I'M GONNA BE YOUR TRAINER.
WE HAVE A PLAN FOR YOU.
YOU'LL FIND THAT OUT SHORTLY
AS WE GO THROUGH IT.
WE'RE GONNA DO A LITTLE TEST--
HEIGHT AND WEIGHT--
TO SEE HOW YOUR BODY WEIGHT
CHANGES OVER THE TIME
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE TRAINING.
Giselle: HAVING
A PHYSICAL TRAINER COME IN
AND TELL US OUR WEIGHT--
THAT WAS A LITTLE KIND OF, UH,
NERVE-RACKING.
Jon: 136.
Giselle: HE SAID IT OUT LOUD.
"136!"
I'M LIKE, OKAY, THAT'S NICE.
Adrianne: I'M THE ONE
THAT'S A BUCK 35, Y'ALL.
>> Jon: 5'9". 5'9".
5'9".
Tessa: YEAH.
Jon: DOES THAT LOOK RIGHT
TO YOU, ABOUT?
Ebony: YEAH.
Jon: NEXT--ELYSE.
Adrianne: ELYSE--SHE HAS NOT
AN OUNCE OF FAT ON HER BODY.
Jon: TERRIFIC. THERE YOU GO.
114.
Women: OH, MY GOD.
Robin: IF YOU'RE
NATURALLY SKINNY,
YOU'RE NATURALLY SKINNY,
BUT WHEN YOU CAN COUNT EVERY,
YOU KNOW, VERTEBRAE,
LIKE, THAT'S SICKLY.
Elyse: AM I THE LIGHTEST ONE?
Katie: YEAH.
Jon: YEAH.
Giselle: I FELT A LITTLE BIG BAD FOR ROBIN
BECAUSE SHE IS THE BIGGER UP--
DOWN HERE IN THE HIPS AND THIGHS
THAN THE REST OF US.
Robin: BEING HERE
IS A BIT AWKWARD,
BECAUSE I AM THE ONLY,
YOU KNOW, "PLUS-SIZE MODEL."
Jon: SEE? LOOK AT THAT?
Robin: I WAS LIKE, "BLEHH!"
Elyse: I THINK FOR ROBIN
IT MUST BE HARD BEING AMONG
GIRLS WHO ARE SO SKINNY.
Robin: SO WE GONNA TAKE OUT
3 POUNDS, SO GIVE ME JUST LIKE,
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYIN'?
Jon: OKAY,
SO WE'LL GO 165.
Robin: YEAH, WE WEIGH 165.
Jon: I WILL SEE YOU AGAIN,
BUT I CAN'T TELL YOU WHEN,
BUT I WILL SEE YOU AGAIN.
Elyse: AND THE SECOND VISITOR
WAS A BIKINI WAXER...
Jonice: HI, GIRLS.
Elyse: WITH HER ENTOURAGE OF
LAB-COATED BIKINI WAX MINIONS.
Jonice: I WAS SENT HERE
BY TYRA BANKS
TO HAVE ALL THE GIRLS
WITH A BRAZILIAN BIKINI WAX.
SO IF YOU DON'T MIND
TO GET ALL THE GIRLS...
Adrianne: I SAW, LIKE,
DEAD FEAR IN PEOPLE'S EYES.
Jonice: YOU ALL GUYS
READY FOR THAT, TO EXPERIENCE?
Adrianne: OH, YES!
VERY MUCH SO.
♪♪♪
Katie: (laughing)
Ebony: I CAN'T BELIEVE
I'M DOING THIS.
Katie: OHH! MAN.
(ripping sound)
Ebony: OHH!
I'M GONNA REALLY WANNA GO
TO BRAZIL BAD!
(laughs)
Adrianne: (screaming)
GISELLE...
ROBIN DEFINITELY DID NOT WANT
TO DO IT.
Giselle: I CAN'T DO THAT.
Shannon: JUST TRY IT.
Kesse: I FELT
EXTREMELY UNCOMFORTABLE
WITH THE BIKINI WAX.
Shannon: OHH!
(ripping sound)
Nicole: OW.
♪♪♪
♪ COME ON, FREAK IT OUT... ♪
Jonice: NO?
Robin: THERE'S ONLY
TWO PEOPLE THAT'S BEEN
DOWN THERE--
MYSELF AND MY GYNECOLOGIST,
AND I GIVE HIM CRAP.
(ripping sound)
Giselle: I'M REALLY SCARED.
I TOLD EVERYBODY
IN MY WHOLE LIFE.
I SAID, "I WILL NEVER GET
A BIKINI WAX."
OH! OH!
(laughing)
AAH!
Robin: COUPLE LADIES
I DON'T KNOW SAYING, YOU KNOW,
"SPREAD 'EM."
(ripping sound)
Giselle: (screaming)
Tessa: THERE'S A FEW GIRLS
THAT I THINK WERE EXAGGERATING
A BIT TOO MUCH.
Giselle: I BETTER BE
A DAMN SUPERMODEL AFTER THIS,
THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY. OH!
♪♪♪
Adrianne: WHOO!
HA HA HA!
HI, EVERYBODY!
I'M SO HAPPY
WE'RE IN NEW YORK CITY.
Robin: WE GOTTA WALK.
Shannon: IT'S FOOD!
Elyse: HEY, GUYS,
WE GOT MAIL!
Katie: WE GOT MAIL?
Elyse: MAIL!
"YOU HAVE A PHOTO SHOOT
FOR J. LO SWIMWEAR
TOMORROW MORNING."
Women: AAH!
Shannon: OH, MY GOD!
Katie: NO WAY!
Elyse: "BE IN
THE HOTEL LOBBY
AT 7:45 A.M. SHARP."
Katie: NO!
Giselle: OH, WAIT, CAN I SEE?
Shannon: THAT'S WHY
WE HAD THE BIKINI WAX!
Katie: SHUT UP!
Adrianne: HOLY...
All: (screaming)
(alarm clock ringing)
(ringing stops)
♪♪♪
Elyse: WE NEED TO BE
IN THE LOBBY OF THE HOTEL
AT 7:45?
Nicole: OH, OKAY,
WHAT TIME IS IT?
Giselle: SO WHAT TIME IS IT,
YOU GUYS?
Adrianne: WE'RE REALLY EARLY.
Elyse: WE'RE SO ON TIME.
EVERYBODY ELSE IS LATE.
Giselle: OH, YEAH.
Adrianne: WE'RE THE REAL MODELS.
WE'RE ON TIME.
Elyse: I WAS IMPATIENT
WITH WAITING FOR THEM.
YEAH, I WAS READY TO GO AT
7:45 LIKE WE WERE SUPPOSED TO.
Kesse: I WAS KINDA TRYING
TO WAIT ON OTHER PEOPLE.
AND BEFORE I KNEW IT,
EVERYBODY ELSE HAD ALREADY
GONE OUT THERE.
I THINK THEY'RE ALREADY GONE.
Robin: ARE YOU SERIOUS?
Shannon: WE ALL GO
DOWNSTAIRS,
AND THERE'S NO ONE THERE.
Robin: WE ALL WERE NERVOUS
BECAUSE WE WERE LATE.
Woman: HEY, GUYS,
YOUR PARTY HAS ALREADY LEFT.
Robin: IT WAS
OUR FIRST PHOTO SHOOT, AND IT
WAS LIKE, "OH, MY GOODNESS.
ARE WE GONNA GET IN TROUBLE?"
Ebony: OKAY.
♪♪♪
Shannon: ROBIN, KESSE AND I
FOUND OUT THAT WE WERE GONNA
BE LATE FOR THE SHOOT.
WE HAD TO FIND
OUR OWN WAY THERE.
SO WE RUN BACK UPSTAIRS,
GET THE ADDRESS,
AND WE TOOK A CAB THERE.
Adrianne: THE GIRLS WHO
ACTUALLY MADE IT TO THE SHOOT
WERE ABLE TO GO
INTO HAIR AND MAKEUP FIRST.
Giselle: DIDN'T EVEN THINK
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
WE FIGURED THE GIRLS
WERE RIGHT BEHIND US.
Shannon: WE WERE, LIKE, ON TOP OF A ROOF,
AND THERE WAS, LIKE, SNOW.
THE WIND WAS BLOWING.
IT WAS FREEZING.
Tyra: HI, EVERYBODY.
Women: HI.
Tyra: BEFORE I START,
I JUST WANNA CALL
A COUPLE OF GIRLS FORWARD.
ROBIN, KESSE, EBONY
AND SHANNON.
I WANT YOU GUYS TO COME FORWARD
JUST A LITTLE BIT.
OKAY, I WAS REALLY UPSET.
I HEARD THAT YOU FOUR WERE LATE.
AND THAT'S JUST NOT ACCEPTABLE.
PHOTO SHOOTS ARE
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS,
AND TIME IS MONEY.
IT'S 100% NOT ACCEPTABLE.
IF THIS WAS A NORMAL SHOOT,
A LOT OF YOU GUYS
WOULD HAVE BEEN SENT HOME.
Shannon: WE'RE BEING JUDGED
ON BEING ON TIME.
I AM VERY NERVOUS
ABOUT THE CUT COMING UP.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT,
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT'S ENOUGH OF THAT.
NOW I WANT YOU TO MEET
YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER FOR THE DAY--
DOUGLAS BIZARRO
AND HIS PARTNER ELIZABETH MOSS.
Douglas: HI, GUYS.
Tessa: HI.
Douglas: HOW Y'ALL DOIN'?
Tessa: FINE.
Douglas: TODAY WE'RE GONNA
BE DOING SWIMWEAR,
AND WE'RE GONNA BE DOING IT
UP HERE ON THE ROOF.
Nicole: WE ALL KIND OF
JUST LIKE, "ARE THEY SERIOUS?"
Giselle: I FREAKED OUT
JUST BECAUSE IT WAS SO COLD.
Douglas: YOU MAY BE
WONDERING WHY WE'RE SHOOTING
OUTSIDE IN THE COLD.
SWIMWEAR IS SHOT
THE SEASON BEFORE.
SO WE HAVE TO SHOOT IT NOW.
Tyra: WELCOME TO
THE BEAUTIFUL, GLAMOROUS WORLD
OF MODELING.
THE ONE MOST COMMON MISTAKE
THAT NEW MODELS MAKE IS,
"THE SEXIER I MOVE,
THE BETTER THE PICTURE
IS GONNA BE."
IT IS ALL ABOUT THIS FIRST.
IT'S ALL ABOUT THE FACE.
YOU HAVE TO ALWAYS BE THINKING
ABOUT SOMETHING.
LIKE A DEAD EYE IS JUST KIND OF
LIKE...
AND THEN AN EYE THAT JUST
HAS SOME FIRE IS LIKE...
SEE HOW IT JUST CHANGES?
YOU CAN CREATE A CHARACTER
WHEN YOU MODEL.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE SILENT MOVIES.
YOU HAVE TO GIVE IT YOUR BEST,
GIVE IT YOUR ALL OUT THERE
AND JUST WORK IT, ALL RIGHT?
AND GOOD LUCK
ON YOUR FIRST SHOOT.
Robin: THANK YOU.
Tyra: YOU'RE WELCOME.
AHH! IT'S FREEZING!
♪♪♪
Douglas: THIS HAS TO BE
THE COLDEST DAY
IN NEW YORK CITY.
Elizabeth: 8-DEGREE
WINDCHILL.
WE'VE WORKED IN A LOT
OF COLD WEATHER.
FOR THIS TO BE
THE WORST CONDITIONS
WE'VE EVER WORKED IN,
AND THIS IS THEIR FIRST TIME,
IT'S CRAZY.
>> Adrianne: WAIT A MINUTE.
I'D SAY IT'S ABOUT 20 DEGREES.
Douglas: NICE. LITTLE BIT.
♪♪♪
>> Douglas: EXCELLENT.
I THINK WE GOT IT.
Adrianne: YES!
Douglas: A MODEL IS MORE
THAN JUST A PRETTY FACE.
THEY REALLY HAVE TO BE
CONFIDENT INSIDE.
THEY REALLY HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO GIVE IT IN FRONT OF THE LENS.
>> Nicole: NORMALLY,
I WOULDN'T REALLY CARE,
BUT IT WAS SO COLD.
I GET COLD IN THE SUN.
I'M COLD ALL THE TIME.
♪♪♪
Douglas: NICE!
YOU LOOK GREAT.
NICOLE WOULD LISTEN TO ME,
AND THAT'S AN IMPORTANT THING
IN A MODEL--IS TO BE ABLE
TO LISTEN TO THE PHOTOGRAPHER.
Tessa: I WAS
A LITTLE NERVOUS, YOU KNOW?
ALL THE OTHER GIRLS
ARE SO SKINNY.
YOU KNOW, I GOT A LITTLE BIT
MORE MEAT TO ME,
BUT I HAD A BLAST.
Douglas: RELAX.
DON'T BE COLD.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
CAN YOU BACK UP A LITTLE BIT?
ONCE I GET YOU
IN THE POSITION THAT WE LIKE,
DON'T MOVE IT AROUND SO MUCH,
BECAUSE I GOT YOU OVER HERE,
AND THEN YOU'RE, LIKE,
OVER HERE, AND THEN...
Tessa: OKAY.
Douglas: YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
THERE YOU GO. THAT'S IT.
TOTALLY. THERE YOU GO. PERFECT.
Elizabeth: SHE PROBABLY HAD
PEOPLE TEACH HER HOW TO MODEL
THE WRONG WAY.
THAT WAS HER PROBLEM.
Elyse: I HAVEN'T LOOKED
THIS GOOD... EVER.
I DID NOTICE ROBIN BEING
A LITTLE MODEST IN HER BIKINI.
SHE HAS A LITTLE MORE INSULATION
THAN ME.
Robin: AAH!
Douglas: ALL RIGHT,
HERE WE GO.
Giselle: ROBIN IS, LIKE,
26 OR 27 YEARS OLD.
I MEAN, HOW MUCH FARTHER
IS SHE GONNA GO, YOU KNOW?
'CAUSE AGE IS A BIG FACTOR
IN THE MODELING WORLD.
Elizabeth: GO LIKE THIS.
Robin: OKAY.
Elizabeth: YOU KNOW WHAT
I MEAN?
THIS LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE TAKING
A CRAP OR SOMETHING, YOU KNOW?
Douglas: CHIN DOWN,
CHIN DOWN. HOLD THAT.
YOU LOOK AMAZING. HOLD IT.
♪♪♪
Douglas: COLD ENOUGH FOR YOU?
Elyse: YEAH.
I THOUGHT I WAS GONNA BE OKAY
UNTIL HAVING TO TAKE OFF
MY BLANKET,
AND WIND WAS JUST COMING
FROM EVERY DIRECTION.
IT MADE IT SO MUCH COLDER.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT,
COME ON, ELYSE.
YOU READY?
>> Elyse: YEAH.
>> Douglas: NICE. HOLD THAT.
GOOD.
Elyse: I HAD TO DROP
MY SHOULDER, KEEP MY ARM IN,
KEEP MY FINGERS TOGETHER
AND MY THUMB HIDDEN,
WHILE HOLDING MY HIGH HEEL
AND SUCKING BACK SNOT.
Douglas: THIS IS PROBABLY
HER FIRST TIME SHOOTING,
SO NOT ONLY IS SHE NERVOUS,
BUT IT'S SO COLD,
THAT SHE JUST CAN'T GET A LOOK.
Elizabeth: SHE WAS
VERY SKINNY,
WHICH MEANS SHE WAS COLD.
SHE GOT TO THE POINT WHERE SHE
COULDN'T EVEN THINK STRAIGHT,
AND SHE STARTED CRYING.
Giselle: ELYSE--YOU KNOW,
SHE HAS THIS SMALL, PETITE BODY,
SO SHE PROBABLY CAN'T
KEEP WARMTH IN.
ELYSE COULDN'T HANDLE IT.
BUT I DID NOT COMPLAIN.
I RIPPED OFF MY BLANKET,
AND I SAID, OKAY.
AND I JUST WENT FOR IT.
Douglas: NICE!
Giselle: BUT IT WAS SO COLD.
I MEAN, EVERYTHING WAS NUMB
FROM MY EARS TO MY HANDS
TO MY FEET TO MY BUTT.
Douglas: GIVE ME MORE HIP
THAT ONE WAY.
YEAH, HOLD IT.
GISELLE DID A GREAT JOB.
YOU CAN TELL WHEN A GIRL
HAS PRACTICED THE MIRROR.
AND LOOK AT ME RIGHT HERE,
PRETTY.
NICE.
♪♪♪
Elizabeth: SHE'S BEAUTIFUL,
BUT SHE DIDN'T REALLY
PHYSICALLY DO ANYTHING
THAT WAS SPECTACULAR.
Douglas: OKAY, GUYS.
Elizabeth: SHE NEEDS TO
SQUINT HER EYES OUT.
>> Douglas: SQUINT YOUR EYES
OUT.
Elizabeth: KATIE WAS ONE
OF THE MOST DIFFICULT ONES.
SHE COULDN'T SEEM TO GET
EVERYTHING RIGHT ALL AT ONCE
AT THE SAME TIME.
NOW SHE'S DOING THIS NUMBER.
IT WAS JUST BACK AND FORTH,
BACK AND FORTH, BACK AND FORTH.
Douglas: GOOD.
HOLD THAT MOVE. NICE.
I THINK SHE WAS GIVING
A LITTLE TOO MUCH.
YOU KNOW, IT WAS LOOKING
A LITTLE ALMOST "PLAYBOY"-ISH.
HOW'S THAT LOOKIN'?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
Elizabeth: THE EYES ARE BIG AGAIN.
Douglas: I DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO SAY.
I MEAN, I ALREADY TOLD HER
20 TIMES.
Elizabeth: IT'S NOT GONNA
GET ANY BETTER.
Katie: I DON'T THINK
IT WAS CHALLENGING.
I THINK IT WAS
A GREAT EXPERIENCE,
AND, YOU KNOW, I'LL DO IT
AGAIN ANYTIME.
Shannon: AAH!
ALL RIGHT, LET'S DO THIS.
PHILIPPIANS 4:13 SAID,
"I CAN DO ALL THINGS THROUGH
CHRIST WHO STRENGTHENS ME."
Douglas: PULL THE HAIR
FROM YOUR CHIN AROUND.
Shannon: AAH!
Douglas: WELL, I DON'T HAVE
TIME TO SIT THERE AND TEACH THEM
HOW TO MODEL.
Elizabeth: YEAH.
>> Douglas: SO SHE NEEDS TO
BRING SOMETHING TO THE TABLE.
Tyra: COUPLE MORE SHOTS,
AND IT'S OVER!
YOU CAN GO WARM, HOT COCOA.
Douglas: AND NOW GIVE ME
EVEN MORE, LIKE REALLY FIERCE.
Shannon: I WANNA WIN
THIS CONTEST.
WORDS CANNOT EXPLAIN HOW BAD
I WANNA WIN.
Douglas: SHE STARTED
FREEZING UP AT THE END THERE.
I JUST COULDN'T GET
THAT FACIAL EXPRESSION.
THAT'S REALLY THE SELLING POINT.
IT'S IN THE EYES.
YOU READY? YOU READY?
♪♪♪
Douglas: YEAH, NICE.
EXCELLENT.
Kesse: WORKING WITH
THE PROFESSIONAL PHOTOGRAPHER
TODAY WAS SUCH
A LEARNING EXPERIENCE.
HE KINDA BROUGHT SOMETHING
OUT IN ME TODAY
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW I HAVE.
Douglas: YEAH. NICE!
EXCELLENT.
KESSE WAS EASY TO SHOOT.
MOST OF THE GIRLS--
THEY HAVE THE BODY,
AND THEN THEIR FACE IS SO COLD,
THEY CAN'T GIVE THE FACE.
WELL, HERS--SHE WAS ABLE
TO GIVE THE FACE.
Elizabeth: I THINK EVERYBODY
DID A REALLY GOOD JOB,
CONSIDERING THE CIRCUMSTANCES TODAY.
Douglas: I'M THINKING
THAT IT'S GONNA BE
A TOUGH COMPETITION WHEN
IT COMES TO THE END OF THIS.
♪♪♪
Man: ENJOY.
Tessa: THE PALM WAS GORGEOUS.
YOU KNOW, GREAT FOOD.
Shannon: OH, MY GOSH!
Adrianne: (laughing)
Elyse: I WAS DRAGGED
OUT OF THE ATHEISM CLOSET.
I DON'T BELIEVE IN GOD,
AND IT CAME UP TODAY AT DINNER.
Robin: DO YOU BELIEVE
IN ANYTHING, UM, ELYSE?
LIKE...
Elyse: I'M AN ATHEIST.
I COULDN'T BELIEVE THE JAWS
AROUND THE TABLE
THAT WERE DROPPING.
Robin: AN ATHEIST? WOW.
Giselle: YEAH, TOUGH SUBJECT.
Robin: I DIDN'T--
I NEVER WOULD'VE LIKE...
WHEN I FOUND OUT
ELYSE WAS AN ATHEIST,
I HAD EXTREME RESERVATIONS
ABOUT HER.
I REALLY FELT SORRY FOR HER.
Elyse: ROBIN, OF COURSE,
QUALIFIES EVERY STATEMENT WITH,
"I'M NOT SAYING
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO HELL,
BUT YOU'RE GOING TO HELL."
JUST BECAUSE I DON'T BELIEVE
IN GOD DOESN'T MEAN
I DON'T HAVE ETHICS AND MORALS.
Robin: I MEAN,
I RESPECT YOU, BUT I MEAN,
I DIDN'T--
I JUST DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
Elyse: I THINK THAT MIGHT BE
ALIENATING ME A LITTLE BIT
FROM THE OTHER GIRLS,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
I'M NOT GONNA PRETEND
THAT I DON'T BELIEVE
IN EVOLUTION JUST SO I CAN
BE FRIENDS WITH ROBIN.
Tessa: WE LOOK OVER,
AND WE HAD TYRA MAIL.
Kesse: "TOMORROW NINE OF YOU
WILL CONTINUE ON TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU WILL BE ELIMINATED."
All: (gasp)
♪♪♪
Elyse: I THINK
I WILL BE ELIMINATED BECAUSE OF
MY POOR PERFORMANCE YESTERDAY.
Tessa: IT KEEPS ON RUNNING
THROUGH MY HEAD,
LIKE, ALL DAY LONG--
TYRA BANKS SAYING,
"TESSA, YOU'RE THE ONE."
I'M JUST SCARED.
Adrianne: I DON'T WANNA
LEAVE.
EITHER I WIN AND MY LIFE
DRASTICALLY CHANGES
FOR THE BETTER, OR I LOSE,
AND I FALL MORE AND MORE
INTO THE HOLE.
Robin: PEOPLE ARE JUST
FEELING KINDA ANXIOUS
AND KINDA NERVOUS.
LIKE, WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
TO EXPECT.
Katie: EVERYONE'S LIKE,
"OH, MY GOD.
YOU KNOW, WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN?"
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, LADIES.
THE TIME HAS ARRIVED
TO MAKE OUR FIRST CUT.
YOU'RE GONNA BE JUDGED
ON YOUR NATURAL TALENT,
YOUR POTENTIAL
AND YOUR PERSONALITY,
AS WELL AS YOUR PERFORMANCE
ON YOUR PHOTO SHOOT
THAT YOU TOOK YESTERDAY.
I HAVE A PANEL OF JUDGES HERE
THAT I TOTALLY RESPECT.
FIRST, WE HAVE
MISS JANICE DICKINSON.
JANICE BECAME ONE OF THE WORLD'S
FIRST SUPERMODELS IN THE 1970s,
AND HER FACE WAS FEATURED
EVERYWHERE.
>> Janice: I'VE BEEN
IN THIS INDUSTRY
FOR QUITE A LONG TIME,
MAKING ME PROBABLY
THE MOST OPINIONATED PERSON
ON THE PANEL.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, NEXT WE HAVE
BEAU QUILLIAN.
BEAU IS THE FASHION EDITOR
AT "MARIE CLAIRE," AND IT'S
HIS JOB TO WORK WITH ALL
THE MAJOR MODELING AGENCIES
TO DETERMINE WHICH GIRLS
HE'S GONNA FEATURE
IN HIS FASHION EDITORIALS.
Beau: IF A MODEL
IS NOT GREAT,
I CAN'T DO ANYTHING FOR HER.
THERE HAS TO BE A BASIC
SOMETHING THERE TO WORK WITH.
Tyra: NEXT WE HAVE
KIMORA LEE SIMMONS.
KIMORA BECAME THE FACE OF CHANEL
AT AGE 13.
SHE'S NOW THE CREATIVE DIRECTOR
AND OWNER OF BABY PHAT,
WHICH IS A SEXY WOMEN'S WEAR
CLOTHING LINE.
Kimora: I THINK YOU HAVE TO
HAVE THAT PERSONALITY
INSIDE OF YOU, THAT DRIVE.
CERTAIN THINGS YOU CAN WORK ON,
BUT I THINK THE BULK OF IT
YOU HAVE TO BE BORN WITH.
Tyra: EACH WEEK WE WILL HAVE
A SPECIAL GUEST JUDGE,
AND TODAY IT IS DOUGLAS BIZARRO.
DOUGLAS IS AN ACCLAIMED
FASHION AND CELEBRITY
PHOTOGRAPHER, AND HE SHOT
YOUR FIRST MAJOR FASHION SHOOT.
NOW WE'RE GONNA BRING YOU IN
ONE BY ONE TO HAVE AN EVALUATION
WITH THE JUDGES.
AND, KATIE, YOU'RE FIRST.
Katie: I WAS REALLY NERVOUS.
I WAS LIKE, "OH, MY GOD."
I WAS, LIKE, SHAKING
WHEN I GOT IN THERE.
Tyra: SO, KATIE, YOU JUST HAD
YOUR FIRST PROFESSIONAL
PHOTO SHOOT, AND WE'VE GONE
THROUGH ALL OF THE FILM.
WE FOUND THE BEST SHOT.
Katie: WOW.
Janice: MY QUESTION IS,
WHAT WERE YOU THINKING,
HOOKING YOUR FINGER
INTO THE BOTTOM OF THE BIKINI?
WHAT WERE YOU THINKING?
Katie: YOU KNOW WHAT?
I WAS JUST THINKING THAT,
YOU KNOW, JUST--JUST THE LOOK.
I THOUGHT IT WAS--
Tyra: I WAS ON THE COVER
OF "SPORTS ILLUSTRATED"
WITH MY HANDS HOOKED.
I'M A LITTLE INSULTED THAT
YOU'RE SAYING
HER HANDS ARE HOOKED.
Janice: SHE'S GOT A LOT OF
WORK TO CATCH UP TO YOU,
MISS THANG.
Tyra: WHAT DO YOU THINK?
Kesse: OH, MY GOD.
THAT IS SO BEAUTIFUL.
I PROMISE. I LOVE IT.
Janice: I REALLY LIKE IT A LOT.
>> Douglas: I DON'T KNOW
IF IT WAS LUCK ON HER PART
OR CONFIDENCE, BUT THIS IS
THE SECOND SHOT
THAT WE TOOK ON HER.
Tyra: OKAY, MISS ADRIANNE.
Beau: CAN I ASK YOU
WHAT SIZE YOUR FOOT IS?
Adrianne: 11.
MY NICKNAME'S
"AIRCRAFT CARRIER."
THE NOTE ABOUT MY FEET
DIDN'T BOTHER ME AT ALL,
BECAUSE WHEN THERE'S
A BIG WOMAN,
THERE TENDS TO BE A BIG BASE.
Janice: FACE IS GOOD.
FOOT--BAD.
Douglas: OUT OF ALL
THE GIRLS I PHOTOGRAPHED,
I WOULD SAY THAT NICOLE
GAVE IT THE MOST.
SHE REALLY HIT IT
AND KEPT WORKING ON HER POSE.
YOU'VE GIVEN ME...
Nicole: THANK YOU.
Douglas: GREAT ANGLES
ON HER BODY.
Kimora: YOU HAVE
A VERY STRONG PERSONALITY,
AND IT SHOWS ON YOUR FACE
AND YOUR POSES.
Janice: TAKE THIS
THE RIGHT WAY.
YOU GOTTA WORK ON THE THIGHS.
YOU GOT THAT BOOTY THANG.
YOU GOTTA KINDA--YOU REALLY
WATCH THE DIET AND EXERCISE,
'CAUSE IT'S NOT ALL ABOUT
YOUR GORGEOUS FACE.
IT IS ABOUT THE BOOTY, TOO.
>> Ebony: I KNOW!
Kimora: I THINK
YOU'RE VERY EXOTIC,
AND YOU HAVE GREAT LONG LEGS.
Tyra: THE MOLE IS GORGEOUS.
DON'T LET ANYBODY EVER TELL YOU
TO TAKE IT OFF.
Douglas: GISELLE,
IN PERSON, NOT MY FAVORITE.
BUT WHEN I GOT YOU ON FILM
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA,
SHE BLEW ME AWAY.
Janice: SHE'S RAIL-THIN.
SHE IS A WAIF.
YOU KNOW, THE RIB CAGE
IS COMING A LITTLE THROUGH IT,
BUT, YOU KNOW, THAT'S OKAY.
SHE'S ONLY 18 YEARS OLD.
Tyra: I LIKE SHANNON'S PERSONALITY.
I THINK SHE GLOWS.
I THINK SHE'S VERY COMFORTABLE.
Douglas: BUT THE NEGATIVE
THING I HAVE TO SAY
ABOUT HER IS CAN TELL
SHE TANS A LOT.
NOW I'M STARTING TO SEE
THAT HER SKIN ON HER FACE
IS ALREADY STARTING TO GET
A LITTLE LEATHERY.
I DON'T NECESSARY THINK THAT
THAT BATHING SUIT,
WHEN SHE CAME OUT,
WAS THE MOST FLATTERING ON HER.
Tessa: I AM ALWAYS THE ONE
THAT STEERS AWAY
FROM ANYTHING THAT HAS TO DO
WITH LITTLE CLOTHES ON.
LIKE, I DON'T EVEN LIKE TO BE
REALLY IN SHORTS.
I ALWAYS, LIKE, TRY TO COVER UP
EVERYTHING.
Janice: I THINK YOU'RE
CHOOSING THE WRONG PROFESSION
IF YOU DON'T WANNA BE
IN LITTLE THINGS
OR YOU'RE TRYING TO COVER UP.
Tyra: OKAY, ROBIN.
Janice: NOW ARE WE SHOOTING
FOR THE LARGE SIZE CATEGORY?
Tyra: UM, YES.
ROBIN WOULD REPRESENT
A PLUS-SIZE MODEL.
ONE PROBLEM THAT I DO HAVE
WITH ROBIN--I THINK ON THE TOP
SHE'S NOT PLUS SIZE,
AND ON THE BOTTOM SHE IS.
Kimora: QUITE HONESTLY,
26 IS A LITTLE LATE TO BE
BUSTING INTO THE TOP MODEL GAME.
Beau: ARE YOU NATURALLY
THAT THIN, OR IS THAT SOMETHING
YOU WORKED TOWARDS?
Elyse: NO,
I AM NATURALLY THIS THIN.
Janice: I LOVE IT.
Tyra: I'M NOT
SO AGAINST THIN, UM,
IF IT'S NATURAL.
Beau: YOU HAVE
NO BODY FAT ON YOU,
SO THERE'S NO INSULATION.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT THIN FOR ME.
THANK YOU.
Tyra: SO WE'VE INTERVIEWED
EVERY SINGLE GIRL,
AND NOW WE HAVE TO COME
AND DECIDE...
Janice: WHO GETS THE AX!
Tyra: WHO GETS THE AX.
ROBIN?
Beau: ROBIN IS FANTASTIC.
Janice: ROBIN'S OUT,
AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT BEING A SUPERMODEL.
Kimora: NO!
Douglas: DEFINITELY NOT.
Kimora: ABSOLUTELY NOT!
Janice: THAT'S
MY HUMBLE OPINION.
Kimora: WHY?
Janice: BECAUSE I THINK OF
THE NEXT AMERICA'S TOP MODEL
IS NOT A PLUS-SIZE MODEL.
I'M SORRY. THAT'S MY OPINION.
Tyra: I LIKE ROBIN.
SHE'S NEAR PERFECTION.
I JUST WISH HER UPPER BODY
WAS BIGGER AND MATCHED
HER LOWER BODY BETTER.
ELYSE.
Janice: IN.
Kimora: OUT.
Douglas: ALONG WITH THE COLD,
IT WAS KINDA HARD FOR HER
TO JUST WORK IT.
WHEN IT CAME DOWN TO CRUNCH TIME
AND GETTING 'EM OUT THERE,
SHE JUST KINDA LOSES IT.
Tyra: KESSE. IT'S SO FUNNY.
I LOOK AT THIS PICTURE, AND IT'S
KINDA FREAKING ME OUT. I'M LIKE,
"IS THIS MY BABY SISTER?"
NICOLE.
Douglas: I THINK NICOLE
DEFINITELY IN.
Beau: NICOLE IN.
Janice: IN.
Tyra: IN.
Kimora: NICOLE IN.
Tyra: SHANNON HAS
PERSONALITY,
AND IT'S ALL ABOUT PERSONALITY.
Janice: I'LL TAKE NICOLE.
I'LL LEAVE SHANNON OUT.
Tyra: SHANNON IS
VERY COMMERCIAL.
SHE'S A PRETTY GIRL,
BUT SHE DOESN'T ADD ANY FUN
OR CREATIVITY TO THE SHOOT.
TESSA.
Kimora: SHE DOESN'T HAVE
A DOMINANT PERSONALITY.
Janice: SHE'S GOTTA BE ABLE
TO SELL PRODUCT.
I'M NOT SEEING ENOUGH
PERSONALITY OUT OF HER.
Tyra: SHE'S ONE OF THOSE,
TO ME, THAT IN PERSON
IS KINDA LIKE, "EHH."
YOU HAVE TO KINDA LOOK STRONG
IN PERSON 'CAUSE THERE'S A LOT
OF PERSONAL APPEARANCES, TOO.
KATIE. IT'S NOT ABOUT
WHO'S SEXY, AND IT'S NOT ABOUT
LOOKING LIKE THE TOP
"PLAYBOY" COVER MODEL.
Beau: KATIE'S GORGEOUS.
Janice: EBONY MOVED
BETTER ANY MODEL DID.
Douglas: OH, COME ON.
Tyra: THEY'VE ONLY BEEN HERE
FOR A WEEK.
Janice: ONLY A WEEK,
AND ONE MUST GO.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, LADIES.
IN MY HANDS ARE NINE PHOTOS,
AND THESE NINE PHOTOS
REPRESENT THE NINE WOMEN
THAT WILL GO ON
TO THE NEXT ROUND
TO POSSIBLY BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
EBONY, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
Tyra: EBONY, YOU'RE STILL
IN THE RUNNING TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
CONGRATULATIONS.
(applause)
Tyra: ELYSE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
(applause)
Tyra: KESSE...
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Kesse: THANK YOU.
Tyra: THE NEXT YOUNG LADY
I'M GONNA CALL...
IS ADRIANNE.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
KATIE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING.
NICOLE.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TO BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Nicole: THANK YOU.
Tyra: GISELLE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
Shannon: I WAS TRYING
TO EXPECT THE WORST,
SO I'M PREPARED TO LEAVE,
EVEN THOUGH IT'S GONNA HURT.
Tyra: THE NEXT WOMAN
I'M GONNA CALL...
IS ROBIN.
THE ONE THING THAT THE JUDGES
LIKE ABOUT YOU IS THAT
YOU REPRESENT THE MAJORITY
OF WOMEN IN AMERICA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO LEFT
IN MY HANDS RIGHT NOW.
WILL TESSA AND SHANNON
PLEASE COME FORWARD?
Tessa: FOR SOME REASON
I HAVE, LIKE, A FEELING IN ME.
IT'S LIKE, OKAY,
"IS IT GONNA BE ME?"
Tyra: WHOEVER'S NAME I CALL
WILL GO ON AND WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE NAME THAT I DO NOT CALL,
YOU WILL BE ELIMINATED
IMMEDIATELY AND MUST SAY
GOOD-BYE TO YOUR ROOMMATES.
Tyra: SHANNON,
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TO BECOMING AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
♪ NEW YORK ♪
♪ TO THE TALL SKYLINE I COME ♪
♪ FLYING IN FROM LONDON... ♪
Tessa: ALL RIGHT, GUYS.
♪ TO YOUR DOOR... ♪
Tessa: LEAVING THE GIRLS
WAS A LOT HARDER
THAN I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE.
♪ NEW YORK ♪
♪ LOOKIN' DOWN ♪
♪ ON CENTRAL PARK... ♪
Tessa: I TRIED.
I MEAN, YOU CAN'T DO
ANY MORE THAN THAT,
AND, UH...
EVERYTHING HAPPENS FOR A REASON,
RIGHT?
♪ NEW YORK ♪
♪ LIKE A SCENE ♪
♪ FROM ALL THOSE MOVIES ♪
♪ BUT YOU'RE REAL ENOUGH TO ME ♪
♪ THERE'S A HEART ♪
♪ A HEART THAT LIVES ♪
♪ IN NEW YORK ♪♪